sin duda los ojos de Ucrania siguen
estando en esa población de bacmut que
ha sido el centro de las grandes
batallas no solamente de las últimas
semanas sino desde el verano cuando las
fuerzas rusas especialmente a sus
paramilitares Wagner empezaron una
ofensiva para tomar el control de una
ciudad en el centro del Don vast famosa
también por sus Minas pero también por
su agricultura pero que según los
militares no tiene un valor tan grande
en esta guerra sin embargo se convirtió
en un objetivo para las fuerzas rusas
que han intensificado esa batalla en los
últimos días la tienen asediada desde
tres frentes diferentes intentan
capturar las poblaciones que están
cercanas todavía en control de los
ucranianos para poder encerrarlas y lo
que han hecho los ucranianos en las
últimas horas especialmente desde ayer
es
destruir el puente de la única carretera
que exponía a la población de chasis
Y eso según algunas organizaciones que
monitorean la guerra podría ser el
preámbulo de una retirada sistemática
sin embargo también se ha visto como en
los últimos días han llegado refuerzos
de fuerzas especiales ucranianas para
apoyar a los soldados que se encuentran
adentro esto en un día en que la región
se encontraba el ministro de defensa
ruso esto se lee de muchos motivos
primero un apoyo a estas fuerzas que
llevan luchando ya desde hace meses en
esta zona pero también para hacer
contrapeso a la presión que le pone el
creador de las fuerzas paramilitares
Wagner que se le ha visto en la zona se
ha dicho que realmente las tropas
ucranianas están prácticamente
encerradas e incluso hoy volvía a
publicar un vídeo bastante fuerte en el
que se veían algunos ataúdes siendo
llevados a un camión y él decía que los
estaba mandando al territorio de kiev en
un honor a estos militares que habían
luchado con bastante decisión y
nacionalismo por su país Así que se está
a la espera de realmente Cuál es la
situación en bakmuth pero lo que dicen
los ucranianos es que siguen luchando
por ella y que siguen en el centro de la
ciudad